[Music]
there are efforts to stop
people from voting that's not right
[Music]
this is not russia this is the united
states of america that was the late
congressman elijah cummings who passed
away
almost a year ago in october of 2019.
now we're learning much more about him
with the posthumous release of
we're better than this his autobiography
the son of sharecroppers cummings rose
to prominence representing maryland's
7th congressional district
becoming a champion for civil rights the
underserved
and the principles of good and fair
government i had a chance to sit down
with cummings widow who helped shepherd
his autobiography
to completion about his extraordinary
life
and that was when his mom got to meet
the president
she was ecstatic maya rocky moore
cummings spent most of 2020
reminiscing and actually that's me with
president clinton
finishing the book started by her late
husband baltimore congressman
elijah cummings did they have a good
relationship
he actually he actually liked
george w as a person he didn't love his
policies
or his politics but he liked the man
it's not about
not liking the president it's about
loving democracy
we're better than this is less memoir
more rebuke
of the partisanship cummings wrote
coming out of the white house
we have a leader who's intent on
dividing people
by race by class by religion by gender
we have a nation that seems to be in
turmoil
over police brutality and certainly
disrupted by the the economy that has
been affected by covet 19.
from the president's policy decisions we
will not
intentionally separate children
from their parents we will not do that
we are better than that
to the misdeeds of mr trump's closest
aides
indicted or convicted of felony crimes
when we're dancing with the angels the
question will be asked
in 2019 what did we do
to make sure we kept our democracy
intact
each chapter from the late chair of the
house oversight committee
weaves a treatise on why cummings felt
mr trump
should be voted out of office but he
firmly believed
that what we're undergoing right now as
a nation between the two parties
is asymmetrical warfare it used to be
that the republicans claim that the
constitution
was one of their highest values and yet
what we saw is a republican party
that was only willing to stand in
defense
of their own power in the beginning
cummings writes
he tried to find common ground attending
mr trump's inauguration when others
didn't
meeting in private with him in hopes of
compromising on the affordable care act
and the high cost of prescription drugs
those people are living in hell
in baltimore donald trump basically
ended up not just
turning his back on elijah but also
denigrating him as a leader
because all that money that's been spent
over 20 years has been
stolen and wasted by people like elijah
cummings
those attacks on cummings and his
hometown
cemented his belief the president was
racist
elijah loved the place baltimore
it hurt him that the president of the
united states of america
would attack a united states city
and act as if it were undeserving the
son
of preachers cummings describes his
childhood in this once
segregated city at eight years old
though he heard some famous words
we must say give us the ballot
we are determined to have the ballot and
we are determined to have it now
he was inspired by the man and the
movement he led
he saw the transformative power of it in
his own life
a transformation that continued when he
marched alongside lawyer activist
juanita jackson mitchell
to integrate baltimore's city pools she
led those kids
on a several day march from their little
segregated pool
to the riverside pool in south baltimore
where
the kids were stoned by white adults
but they got in that pool and they
integrated it and continued with another
woman
his political mentor lena king lee
she was a maryland state legislator and
she wanted
to find a female attorney to follow her
into the state legislator but she
couldn't find one so she approached
elijah
she told him she was looking for a
female attorney he said he would try to
help her find one but she was just like
no you'll do
did he ever ask why me i believe
he asked what she saw in him and
she indicated that his willingness to
to serve other people was what inspired
her
do you still feel him here i feel him
every day i am surrounded by elijah
cummings
the two met more than 20 years ago after
rocky moore cummings interviewed the
freshman congressman
for her doctoral dissertation she later
became a policy maker
before they connected romantically it
was a dance
but you know from 1998 to
2005 we just developed a very strong
friendship from 2005
it became a committed relationship and
we got married in 2008
for maya rocky moore cummings the last
two years have been a whirlwind
she bowed out of maryland's
gubernatorial race to care for her
husband
published his book after his death
underwent a double mastectomy
and then lost her bid for his vacant
congressional seat
yeah it's been a rough time how are you
making it through
you know i have faith in god now
she's looking beyond and like her late
husband
has faith in what could lie ahead he
wanted the american people to
call on their higher beings
their inner angels to understand that
we don't have to go through this we
deserve better than this
and we are better than this all we have
to do
is make our choice to be better
and you know so much of elijah cummings
uh
legacy is is part of the elijah cummings
uh foundation for youth and there's so
many people that have come
out of that that program in terms of
helping them find their leadership
helping them move into college uh 20
years down and it has
you know hundreds and hundreds of kids
uh that have become adults
that some are on television some are you
know in
uh a political office so it's just an
amazing it's an amazing thing to see how
the legacy lives on
what strength she shows it's always so
difficult when someone's unable to
finish a book when they're alive and
then the burden that falls on family and
relatives to
uphold that legacy and tell the story
they wanted to
the way to tell it yeah thanks for
sharing it yeah great
still tough for her yeah